let's talk about the foods that can
potentially boost libido
both in men and women so we're talking
about
foods that have an aphrodisiac effect so
i first want to tell you if you're not
sleeping if you have too much chronic
stress
if you consume a high carb high sugar
diet
then none of these are going to work
because these will very easily nullify
libido so testosterone is the hormone
that tends to increase the libido
in both men and women but of course with
women they don't need much because if
they have too much testosterone or other
androgens
what's going to happen is they're going
to get facial hair
and they're going to get a deeper voice
and they'll lose their hair on the top
of their head
and a lot of other issues so
we're just talking about the right
balance now anything that increases
estrogen too much
will lower testosterone and lower libido
and that would be
alcohol dairy
too much dairy could potentially give
you too much estrogen and of course
soy soy oil soy protein
isolates can lower
testosterone and then tap water um
make sure you get a filter there are all
sorts of chemicals
and hormones in tap water including
estrogen so that can be a big problem
all right so let's say these are handled
right here okay pistachios
pistachios are high in this amino acid
called arginine
which increases nitric oxide which
guess how viagra works by increasing
nitric oxide and so pistachios can help
to a certain degree and also selenium
can increase
not just fertility but can actually help
healthy testosterone levels
all right number two oysters why because
out of all the foods out there oysters
have the most zinc and zinc is one of
the most powerful
minerals to increase testosterone levels
also oysters have copper which also can
help testosterone levels
as well as selenium all right number
three
coffee coffee will do two things if you
have too much
that can lower testosterone if you have
just a little bit that can help
the caffeine and the polyphenols
will help support healthy testosterone
levels
and then we get this herb called saffron
it's very very expensive
but they even use it to treat depression
it can increase your mood
and it can increase fertility and then
we have number five maca root
they call it the peruvian viagra it can
increase
testosterone number six asparagus
in asparagus you have this natural
steroid building block that can actually
help you increase your testosterone
levels of course we're not talking about
you know the steroids that someone would
inject themselves with
as a bodybuilder all right next one
truffles so truffles are a type of
mushroom
there's been some interesting studies
that it can increase testosterone
all right number eight beets can
increase nitric oxide
like pistachios now if you're on keto
make sure you don't do
too many beets because they are a bit
higher in sugar but a small amount is
going to be totally fine
but again none of these are going to
create any effect unless you're sleeping
keep your stress down and you're on a
low carb
diet and of course exercise also will
help too
all right thanks for watching hey before
you go real quick
i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it
and here's why here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding your environment but what about
here
what about strengthening your immune
system
that's what's missing this course will
show you how to bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today